ease but that yougov polling out today
with party members shows that rishi
sanak will struggle to beat any of the
other three with party members this poll
was taken uh yesterday and today he
loses against every single candidate now
what does it tell us about what rishi
sunak might do if he can lend votes
that's when you lend votes to another
campaign to block an opponent he's not
there yet he doesn't have enough in his
locker to do that yet but that poll
suggests that it might be easier for him
uh to get past penny mordent uh than liz
truss uh so maybe he'll go that way but
really what we're waiting to see as well
sj is how will the tom tugan hat vote
break tom tugan had knocked out
yesterday one of the one nation tories
he had 31 votes to redistribute those
votes i hear are splitting between rishi
sanak and penny morden so what am i
expecting i'm expecting penny mordant to
make some progress i expect richardson
that should get across the line and then
it's this battle between trust and
badernock i think we've got the results
before uh i will read the name of the
candidate in alphabetical order with the
number of votes cast for that candidate
and then
specify
the candidate to be eliminated from the
election
bad enoch 59 votes
mordent 92 votes
sunak 118 votes
trust 86 votes
there was one spoiled ballot paper
we had
a full term
we had one vote not cast
so kemi badanok
is eliminated from the election the
remaining three candidates will proceed
to a final ballot of the parliamentary
party tomorrow this will take place
i mean this time i will take place
between one and three
with the results declared at four
o'clock tomorrow afternoon
um let's just recap the figures for you
then uh kemi badanok is out of the tory
leadership race she got 59 votes and
that's the same and that that means she
is out of the running and then there
were three uh rishi sunak getting the
most votes 118 that's three more than he
got in the last round by my calculation
penny mordent um the second highest
number of votes with 92 10 more than she
got in the last round of voting and liz
trust is on
86. um and i'm just trying to do the
maths on that that is nine about 12 more
i think actually beth will know more
let's bring back in our political editor
beth rigby and so kemi badanok gone um
and as you said before that's probably
no surprise but the big question is who
does she put her support behind now out
of those final three
yeah i i think i think astray that the
fast thing to say about it is that bad
enough did not make progress in fact she
went worn back so what do we know from
that the right is now coalescing around
liz trust she has had a good run there
she has added 15 votes from the last
round that is good momentum for liz
trust the right now coalescing some of
badernock's vote may be going to her
let's see with that but then also with
penny mordant she's gone from 81 to 92
so 11 of the tom uh tougan heart vote so
i'm just looking around to see what mps
are here uh 11 of the uh
toughen heart votes have gone to morden
so now look at that it's a real battle
between mordent and trust um rishi sunak
didn't quite get past the 120 threshold
but let's see where the bada knot votes
break now will she go to liz
uh will she break for rishi sunak will
michael gove break for rishi sanak he
backed badernock where will he go there
are
59 votes up for grabs and it will be
those votes that decide whether it's liz
trust or penny morden in to the final
two there is now just uh six votes uh
um uh dividing uh the two women this is
such a tight run race to get to the
final two so let's see how the badder
knot broke breaks now but rishi sunak
not quite over the line actually there
um beth thank you and kevin vadernock
actually gained one extra vote but is
still out so that's regardless we're
doing the maths on the hop here aren't
we beth so uh penny morden picking up 10
rishi soon at picking up three liz
trusts as you said the big winner today
in that respect picking up 15. explain
to us what happens now with the final
three are you sorry oh no sorry beth i
was just saying what happens now with
the final three where did where does
this contest now go
in terms of procedure so sj now what we
have uh tomorrow is we have another
round of votes and it will be decided uh
by mid-afternoon tomorrow we will know
uh who is in the final two rishi sunak
is pretty assured of getting across the
line he's just two votes off now from
that magic 1 20 and it is going to be a
hell of a battle between penny mordant
and liz trust but from the trust team
there a bit underwhelming last night
just putting on seven votes you expected
more perhaps because the braverman
column you thought might split more for
liz trust but over the past 24 hours
clearly the right of the party have
decided it was time to get behind liz
trust she's now just six votes off penny
morden you've got to wonder how much
more of mordant sorry bad enough vote
can penny mordant pick up given that uh
kemi badnik is clearly not a fan of
penny morden you've seen her take her to
task on some of the gender self-id
legislation and some of the
trans-issue debate kemi badanok not
aligned with penny mordant but who will
badon operate for will she break for
rishi sunak will she break for liz trust
it is really wide open still but i think
if you're in the trust camp now you will
be more confident that she can edge past
penny mordant but it just really does
depend now where those 59 votes break
and i think there will also be a
calculation overnight from the rishi
sunni sonic camp about where would he
who would he prefer to face in the final
two and does his team uh begin to
slightly try and move the votes around
to block one candidate in favor of the
other i should say that his team have
consistently said that they aren't doing
that but might it be that rishi sunat
would prefer to face down penny mordant
in the finals to than the foreign
secretary liz trust i really couldn't
give you a prediction right now about
which of those two women are going to
face rishi sonic in the final
interesting development though we
touched a little earlier that yougov
poll saying that rishi sunak
whatever woman he faces will really
struggle why do you think that is
the thing is sj at the moment he would
really struggle but i think there is a
view in his camp
that as the race goes on he will be able
to demonstrate to the party membership
uh that he is the person uh that is most
able to take uh helm of the government
and hit the ground running so that will
be uh the sunup position but you you're
right i mean for him it is difficult
when he looks into that run-off and he
can see that both women are more popular
than him with the party members so he's
got some ground to make up what might it
be could it be disloyalty to boris
johnson do they not like his tax
policies do they not like the taxation
levels that he's put on the country and
in that liz trust is therefore a potent
opponent because she is the one that's
positioning herself as the tax cutter
you saw her in that itv debate taking
aim at rishi sanak for to quote her
bringing about the highest taxation in
this country for uh 70 years i've
actually if you don't mind sj i've
actually got chris skidmore here
he is on team rishi
hi chris thanks for joining me um
your man's still not in the final two
you've got to be disappointed in that
he's two votes away two votes away from
the final two 120 you know is the
threshold and i think you that looks
incredibly realizable uh given obviously
sort of kemi's team i think some of
those will come across
and once he's through the final two i've
got no doubt that he will impress the
membership you know with his vision of
being able to demonstrate that we don't
need to go down this route of tax cuts
you know we need to provide stability
but but chris there was an expectation
today that the tom tuggenheart vote
would split between sunak
and mordent and it hasn't done that he's
only made
three only three votes going his way i
mean what's what's happening is he
stalling well i think you know when it
comes to these predictions you might as
well sort of be looking at the tea
leaves i think to be honestly everyone
sort of said oh bad knock might overleap
trust she only gained i think one vote
in the end so and everyone said oh two
can happily a lot of those might back
kemi so who knows what's going on i
wouldn't also put it past you know some
of the other teams to be doing a bit of
horse trading
what do you mean by that well there may
be some rival teams backing others to
try to get through to that final second
spot i think when you explore i don't
understand that can you explain that so
it might be that you have some people on
team trust versus some people on team
morden who are trading their votes
around and i think you know it's very
clear to me that
rishi is so closely across the line but
the battle is about the second place now
and actually it's on a knife edge
whether it's liz whether it's penny i
don't know
i mean i can't call it can you no i
obviously can't i think anyone need have
no do you not think liz is edging it
given that the bad or not votes more
likely to break for her than for more we
just we just said that we thought some
of the two can have votes we're going to
break for rishi so actually i think what
you've got is it's not just a sort of
left right split here there's lots of
different issues i mean if you look on
the right for example there's this
genuine split over trans right it's not
something you know i particularly think
is a priority for voters in this country
but some mps are deciding their vote on
the basis of that and not going for
penny and instead of going for lists and
chris just finally there's a poll out by
yougov today i mean basically rishi
sunup might be winning with mps but he's
tanking with party members every single
candidate b every single panda date in a
poll beats rishi sunnah you've got to be
worried about that so that poll is
really interesting because if you
compare it with last week's yougov poll
rishi has gone up in in his position
though no he's still losing against some
of the newer candidates so penny went
down 16 points but she went she was up
at 62 and she's now down at 50 something
kemi's now come up because obviously
kemi's featured the debates these are
tiny sample sizes and actually what
you're seeing is certain new candidates
coming towards the public the first time
they're saying oh great new candidate
rishi has a record in government which
obviously for some people he's been a
chancellor and with these taking
difficult decisions taking difficult
decisions means sometimes you're going
to be unpopular but having that record
in government is a real advantage if we
want a prime minister at the end of this
who's going to lead i've got i've got a
throwback final question one answer who
would he fear the most in the final
trussell morden oh difficult question i
think
i think when it comes to the right i
want to i want an answer chris all right
well i think sort of rishi versus liz is
going to be the sort of most feared
contest in terms of that will be a
battle for ideas or other battle
personalities so really he'd quite like
mordant to go through thinks he can beat
her on competence i think it's a
question of competence and experience
and rishi clearly has that for the vast
experience thank you so much thank you
um estrella i've got other people to
talk to but i think i need to throw back
to you now but come back to me uh when
you can let's rejoin beth and she has
more guests with her in central lobby we
have had a statement from penny morden
who remains in second place she says
this afternoon colleagues once again put
their trust in me and i cannot thank
them enough we are so nearly across the
finish line i'm raring to go and excited
to put my case to members across the
country and win
i want to pay tribute to kemi badanok as
she goes on to say she and i both know
that the old way of government isn't
working as it should voters want change
and we owe it to them to offer a bold
new vision for this country kemi's
passion for this showed and i'm glad she
put herself forward to be heard so
that's penny morden's response what's
the reaction there in central lobby beth
hi sj well i'm i'm joined by lee
anderson who was a backer of kemi
badanot now out of the race
lee she she ran a good race i mean she
did impressively well but then stalled
in this round what what happened i don't
know i think but maybe some mps got cold
feet weren't quite brave enough to to
back camilo in every single poll gone
home every poll i've seen over the past
24 hours kemi comes out on top and each
head to head pole she comes out on top
as well but i think you know what some
of the members won't like i said weren't
quite brave enough to give her that
extra shove that she needed but hey a
couple of years time five years time ten
years time came here with prime minister
of this country absolutely no doubt
about that she and tom tugan heart in
different ways for different wings of
party have been standout stars of this
campaign that's fair isn't it yeah they
offer something new uh we you know i
didn't want a continuity um prime
minister which is probably what we're
gonna get now i was looking for
something totally fresh something new
something with with new ideas i think
kevin and both tom offered that and the
people like that and
who are you gonna back now well that's a
conversation i'd like to have with the
other candidates i've got my shopping
list on my office desk obviously we're
going to see the candidates over the
next 24 hours and whoever impresses me
most and who offers the other offers the
best deal for ashford and the uk will
get my vote
and lee who do you think will get into
the final two i mean it's it it's so
tight now isn't it between morden and
trust well you'd be a forty back against
richard because he's been the the front
one of you know from day one so he looks
like he's got one one foot in the final
it depends now where uh where kemi's
votes go i don't know um because a lot
of us are expecting kevin to go through
today so we've got to have that
conversation with ourselves have you
ever backed penny morden or is it just
one nation isn't for you well i wait
till i want me to speak to penny first
and liz and richie then i'll make my
mind up and i'll let you know tomorrow
better thank you for coming on and
talking to if you don't mind i'm gonna
um sj i'm going to bring in andrew
ledson is campaign manager for penny
mordent so she's still second andrea
uh but liz trust is catching up now only
six votes separate them you've got to be
worried about that
well first of all a huge tribute to kemi
because she's really really fought for
this and it is brutal you know these
leadership hustings are so difficult
yes i mean penny has gained support
today and that's brilliant because it's
from all parts of the party and we are
incredibly optimistic about tomorrow but
ultimately you know this is a decision
of all of our mp colleagues penny is
fighting a positive clean campaign is a
campaign that will reunite the party and
win the next general election
andrew ludson though the bad or not vote
i mean kami badanok has made it very
clear that she is not
in any way a supporter of penny morden
she's had warm words uh to rishi sonat
she's more identified politically with
liz trust and she has made countless
attacks on penny morgan there's just no
way that she's going to back morden i
mean i put it to you that penny could
well get squeezed in this final round
the thing is that's to assume that
people vote on block you know you accept
my analysis or you don't no no i i
absolutely don't know i mean penny and
kemi have worked together over the years
leadership hustling that's been taking
chunks out of her over her position on
transition i'm gonna say beth if you let
me say that leadership hustings are a
brutal time you know i've been through
this myself you've been through this a
lot you know
that very often people say things in the
heat of the moment but the reality is
penny and kemi have a strong
relationship and it's simply not true
that all mps voters are blocked you know
kemi doesn't command the the block vote
in the same way that none of the lead
leadership contenders command some sort
of block vote people make their own
decisions penny is fighting a clean and
positive campaign where she wants to
make her case to win the next general
election to reunite the party to grow
our economy those are the things that
she will be appealing to people and you
know she sends her very best wishes to
kemi
and andrea um chris skidmore just said
to me when i pressed him about sunak and
who he'd rather he fear the most in the
final round he said it was liz trust
because of the kind of very different
economic positions uh that sonak and
trust have that's going to help morden
isn't it because sonic backers might
push your women through in order to
block liz
you know i don't actually believe that
lots of colleagues vote tactically um in
fact you know having talked to
colleagues most will say no i'm going to
support the person i'm supporting i'm
not interested in that sort of
shenanigans you know people accuse mps
of all sorts of things but when it comes
to leadership hustings colleagues do
absolutely go for the person they think
will be the best one to run the country
so i don't really accept that thesis
that somehow people will switch to the
least this or the most that but but
nevertheless penny is going to be
talking to lots more colleagues this
evening who said you know if their
candidate falls they would be very keen
to talk to penny so we're very
optimistic
andrew i just if you indulge this
question you did this in 2016 and it was
quite brutal for you
how's it been been at the side of penny
morden seeing her
attacked very personally on the front of
papers every day
has it brought has it brought back bad
memories views it's been quite hard um
well you know this isn't about me i
suppose the advantage is having been
through it i'm able to say to her look
this is just what happens you know we're
fighting a clean campaign it's right
that people scrutinize somebody who
wants to lead what i think is and what
penny thinks is the greatest country on
earth so this is this is just part of it
and actually what's brilliant about
penny is she's coping with it so well
and she just moves on she's got a very
positive tenacious spirit and she just
wants to put her positive case to the
country just one other thing
a yougov poll out today last week
mordant was winning with party members
this week she's not i'm afraid to say
that it seems andrea in terms of the
interview she's done in the tv debates
the more the party members have seen
of penny morden the less they want her
you know that is it no no that that i i
completely refute that the fact that the
polls show that she's losing last week's
polls showed that penny could beat
kierstama in london so in a labor city
penny can beat
labour and i'm just saying the more that
following all the major rounds that
she's done the more she's been out the
less she's impressed so
you know i i think that there's a long
way to go for the members to see pennies
appeal to the country and these
short-term polls they just give one
thing and then another thing you can't
draw any conclusions from those what we
actually need is to see two people in
the final both of whom could win a
general election penny mordant will
definitely in my opinion win that
general election she has broad appeal
right across the country and in all
demographics okay andrea thank you so
much for me what are you going to be
doing for the next 24 hours no sleep
well talking to colleagues on behalf of
my friend penny
and she is so grateful she's got so many
wonderful colleagues helping her so yes
not much sleep thank you andrea thanks
so much for joining us on sky news uh so
there you go andrea led some thinking
that her woman will get through
to the end but actually the polls are
narrowing and liz truss is making up
ground and i'm joined if you don't mind
s j i'll stay here i'm joined by ed
arghar
one of liz truss's backers
bit of momentum there you've got to be
pleased with that huh it's a great
result for liz she put on the most votes
in that round of all the candidates and
she's made steady progress throughout
this contest in building up her vote but
also very impressive run there by kemi
who's helped shape the debate in this
leadership contest i don't think we've
heard the last of kemi um
do you think
are you more confident now that liz can
get to the final two
well i'm working flat out for liz i'm
confident she can do that we've seen
that momentum building we've seen those
votes and solidly steadily building up
for her throughout all the rounds of
this um
of this contest put on i think 15 votes
in this last round the most of any of
the candidates in terms of again and
since that first round of voting aside
from rishi she's the person who's put on
the most why did bada not stall do you
think it just because in the end the
right were like we can't keep splitting
the vote between trust and baddernock
and there was this moment where it's
like we need to get serious now is that
what happened this round i thought henry
might make some more progress well i
take issue with your point about getting
serious now i think kemi is a very
serious candidate and i think she's
she's had a brilliant campaign make the
weather in elements of this campaign
she's run a fantastic campaign
and i think she's brought to this some
really really interesting ideas and i
you know how these um these contests run
you've seen many of them this is my
third one i think since i was elected in
2015.
different colleagues vote for different
reasons um and you see that momentum
building for different candidates at
different points
that's why i think it's it's important
to know that you know
liz is the one who's seen that steady
momentum throughout without a fault or
without anything else so she's she's the
one i think who's uh making the running
and
final qu final question um chris
skidmore just told me that if it was a
run-off between liz
and
rishi tsunak or
penny and rishi sunak that actually it
would be liz trust that sonic might fear
the most in the final two she's foreign
secretary but also she has a very
different economic vision for the uk are
you worried that there could be a bit of
skullduggery now and actually in the end
the rishi team block liz truss in order
to put who he thinks will be the weaker
candidate in the final two you've got to
be worried about that and i think
colleagues will vote for the person they
think is best placed to be prime
minister and that's the right thing are
you not worried about that come on no
i'm confident liz has put forward a very
clear and compelling vision for the
economy for the country
she's got that depth of experience just
as you've alluded to so does rishi they
are different people but they're both
very talented people i think colleagues
will see that and they will support let
me put it the other way what's your
message to sunak's team my message is
that we have a huge array of talent
which you've seen throughout this
contest rishi liz kemi penny tom a whole
range of people
all putting forward their views all for
putting forward their agenda in a
positive way i think this reflects very
well on the conservative party and i
think they are all extremely able and
talented people dargah thanks so much
for joining me uh so there you have it
sj the verdicts of
a bad enoch supporter now she's knocked
out trusts morden and sonak backers
there it's a battle between uh mordant
and trust now who's going to make the
final two